La amenaza de una toma por parte de
Rusia es cada vez más real en el pueblo
de krasnofilia situado en el noreste de
Ucrania los disparos suenan
constantemente aquí las fuerzas de Moscú
están a sólo 10 kilómetros de distancia
y los soldados ucranianos están en
alerta máxima
lo siento es demasiado tenso ahora no
puedo hablar con usted
estos trabajadores de rescate están
esperando a las tropas heridas en el
frente a medida que llegan es una
carrera contra el reloj para salvarlos
mientras el ejército ucraniano ha
admitido que está perdiendo terreno en
esta zona las fuerzas rusas han avanzado
varios kilómetros en los últimos días el
principal objetivo de Vladimir Putin en
la guerra es hacerse con el control del
Don base en el este sin embargo las
fuerzas ucranianas dicen que no lo
permitirán y están decididas a oponer
una dura resistencia a pesar de los
desafíos a los que se enfrentan
estamos reuniendo nuestras tropas aquí
cada dos días llegan más hombres vamos a
defender nuestro territorio y a hacer
retroceder a los rusos
también tiene sus ojos puestos en la
ciudad de esloviansk situada a pocos
kilómetros los residentes de esta ciudad
están en constante alerta esto se
evacuados que huyen de la violencia
acaban de llegar los pueblos cercanos
esperan subir a un tren que abandone la
hace día a la región
debemos salvarnos
volveremos y todo volverá a la
normalidad
mientras la región se prepara para unos
combates más intensos las autoridades
ucranianas han advertido a los
residentes que esta es la última
oportunidad para escapar